Hannah brown Alan how are you guys happy
CMAs day
have you seen amazing to you I'm excited
I am I'm like can't even contain my
excitement I'm so excited to be here
like I just look around and I'm like oh
my god I love you I like your song
I have your love like it's just is so
fun who's gonna be the biggest person
you guys are gonna fangirl over tonight
I for me Garth Brooks because I've
always wanted to meet him like I think
he just seems like the coolest guy ever
and I I went to one of his concerts and
it was just an experience unlike any
other so I'm really excited to meet him
what about you I'll take the little
non-sex he's a winner tonight our winner
yeah you know when I saw that you were
gonna be here I was like you know what
we gotta set her up with some country
artists here she I mean would you be
down for that is there anyone that
you're crushing on here at the CMAs um I
feel like everybody's like a lot of
people are taken people are taking so I
don't know there's still some eligible
eligible bachelor hey well I mean Brett
L dream I'm a single like Morgan Wallen
so you would be down for a country star
to kind of slide in those DMS or even
you know chat with you tonight I mean
that's not like my first priority right
now
I am definitely focused on being in the
semifinals for date some of the stars
but oh sorry about that thing but I'm a
single lady I like country music they
could serenade me well very well best of
both world yeah so be you know obviously
you had a relationship with someone who
was a singer that said I didn't turn you
off at all no I can't I can't be mad or
be turned off by all musicians so
do you want to see her with a country
star why not you guys want to see them
she loves country music you guys just
want to see the Mirrorball trophy I know
I see it in your eyes are you guys
nervous at all I mean you have a really
great shot oh my god good okay I always
get nervous because it's something that
I have like invested everything into it
this point man we were up at 6 a.m.
rehearsing this for this and so it is
just something that's really been a
special part of my journey and I would
love to have that in-game be with a
beautiful trophy and my matches her
dress is truly going yeah but this is my
way of manifesting it just wearing a
mere ball
[Music]